ええええええ
いいいい
me
みなさんこんにちは写真家をしております大村百合子と申します
突然ですがみなさんこの中にいらっしゃる方でもう人生をかけてやりたいことが
見つかっているという方はどのくらいいらっしゃるでしょうか
いいですね一方でまだやりたいことが分からない
見つからないという方も多いのではないでしょうか
実は私もそんな中のひとりでした
かなり大人になるまで自分のやりたいことが何なのかというのはずっと分かりません
でした
大学生の時はまあ法学部の法律学科の卒業なので自分が写真家になるなんていうことは
1ミリも想像していませんでした
本日は写真が支えてくれた私の人生というタイトルでお話をさせていただきたいと思い
ます
はい改めまして写真稼働ブラーですよろしくお願いします
私はですね社員1983年生まれ現在36歳です
小学校の時から慶應義塾で育ってきました
おじが漫画の編集者だったということもありまして
小学生の頃の夢は漫画家になることでした
エアイラストを書くのが非常に好きな子供でした
小学校4年生の時に振るとあのなぜだかハ習い始めましてそれでですね中学と高校は
それに従ってオーケストラをやる部活に入っていました
ま中高生の時はですねもう朝から晩まで音楽のことを考える生活を送っていました
それで
あのフルートが好きだったので音楽大学に行きたいなとこそれを持っていたんです
けれども
あの楽器の先生にですねあなたは慶應義塾大学にそのまま進学できるのです
だからそうしなさいと言われまして文系だったということもありまして
法学部の法律学科に進学することにしました
でですね大学生になると魔法学部の法律学科だったので
まあ友達たちはですね法律家を目指してあの司法試験に合格するための勉強を始めてい
たんですね
って当時私はの将来に関して明確なビジョン全く描いていなかったので友達がやってる
から自分もやってみようということで
あのね
がされるがままにですねちょっと使用試験の勉強などを始めてみました
肌ですねあのーもしをし検討者の
コアの東華大学院制度がなかったので
現行の使用試験に挑戦するということだったんですがとにかく大変です大学と並行して
使用試験の予備校というものにも通ってみたんですがもうインプットもアウトプットも
ですね想像以上の量で
あと今更こんなときに気づくなよって事なんですけど
あの私椅子に長時間座って何かを語を勉強するというのがあんまり向いてないという
ことに気づきまして
あっという間に勉強するのが嫌になっちゃったんですね1棟まあまあこの
は向いてないんじゃないかと思いました
ただですねやはり大学4年生になるとまロースクールまだできていませんでしたので
司法試験に現役で合格するという友達がちらほら
現れ始めました
その時ですね私は人生で初めて焦りというものを感じました
そのまあ合格した友達たちはですねまぁどこの法律事務所に就職しようとかそういった
将来のことを考えて話をしているわけです
では人生でやりたいことを見つけて着実にっ子歩き出しているわけです
ただそのときは私は本当にやりたいこともなんだ
は分かりませんでしたしもうその友達の話を聞いて非常にあった自動したらいいん
だろうと思うようになりました
でですね大学4年生の時に今一度自分は何がしたいのかということを考え直してみまし
た
その時ですねあの思いついたというかあのー思い当たったのがもっともっとやはり a
ですとか音楽とかそういったちょっとグリーティ部なことが好きだったので
者当時あの流行しておりました
web
乗って仕事なんかどうだろうと思ったんですよねっ
なのでまぁちょっと web なんかを仕事にしてみたらいいんじゃないかとその時に
思いました
それで大学4年生の時にあの web の専門学校に並行して通いまして
大学卒業と同時にですね web デザイナーとして活動を始めることにしました
であの陶楽部の公立学校のゼミに入っていたんですけれどもやはり友達たちはみんな
法律家を目指しているわけです
そんな中でですね卒業式のときにあの私 web デザイナーになりますって言った時
にはもうゼミの皆 a っていう風に言ったのを今でもすごく覚えています皆さんも
そんな人いたらええってなりますよねはいあそんな
あの時代がありました
でですねあのまあお店の先写真先に出しちゃったんですが
ウェブデザインの仕事は非常に楽しくてですねあのまあ生きていけるぐらいの収入は
あの得ることができました
なんですけれどもまあ何年かやっていくうちですねこれ本当に私が一生かけてやりたい
ことなのかだろうかと
やっぱり疑問に思っ
てしまったんですね
であのまぁそんなモーモンとした状態だったんですけれども
ホームページ何かお仕事でつくる上でやはり写真っていうのはどうしても必要になって
くるんですね
でそのホームページの素材として使う写真というのは
はカメラマンさんに撮影を頼んだりですとかしていたんですけれどもやはりちょっとお
値段高かったりですとか
あとイメージ通り
にならないということが多々ありまして
これはちょっと
まあ自分で写真撮れたらいいんじゃないかなと思うようになりました
そこでですねただまぁ写真といっても私はためらのかの字ももう知らないような人間
だったので取り急ぎですね
デジタルの一眼レフを購入しまして
3ヶ月でカメラの使い方がわかるみたいな学校にですね通いました
ただまぁそれだけではちょっと勉強として不十分だなと感じましたので今こちらの
スライドに出ている
これカメラカメラとお店なんですけれども
知り合いがたまたまあの街のカメラ屋さんの店長しておりまして
まぁそこにですねアルバイト買ったら勉強させてもらうのはどうだろうかと思いました
それであのこちらは赤坂見附にある赤坂さん今日カメラてお店だったんですがそこであ
のアルバイトとして採用していただくことになりました
このときはまだ web の仕事もあの並行して続けていました
エアのこちらの明坂さん今日カメラは街の写真屋さんなのでばプリントですとか
フィルムの現像なんかをする一方で体幹などのクラシックカメラまフィルムカメラです
ね
なんかもう当たったの販売をしていました
で私は主に仕事としてはあの機械を使ってお客様の持ち込まれたデータをプリントする
というのがメインの仕事だったんですけれども
だんだんですねあのお客様が持ち込まれる
フィルムカメラの写真がとても美しいということに気づきましてですねだんだん
プリント当初の目的を忘れ will まカメラ
の方にこうのめり込むようになっちゃったんですあのこういったカメラ等です
このカメラ達まぁ本当に外見も非常にエトロでね可愛いんですよこれ全部私のカメラな
んですけど
非常に可愛くて好きですただなによりも好きだったのはこういったフィルムカメラです
パパ写真というのはですねこうその場の空気感までも何か移すようなちょっとべじたる
とは違う趣があったんですね私はもうそれに
非常にどんどんとりつかれていきました
こちらあの実際このフィルムカメラで私が撮影した写真なんですけれども
あのーまあとにかくこういった写真が撮れるってまぁ振り返ってみると私はそれまでの
人生では何かを表現したいなと思ってきたんですけれどもまあその手段が何なのかって
いうのをいまいち分からないままに割と大人になってしまう
たんですがこの上にもカメラに撮った写真を見た時にあっこれは私の表現したいものを
ありと摘んだりと表現できて気持ちがいいぞって思ったんですね
はい
でそれでもうどんどんこういったあのフィルムカメラで写真を撮るようになりまして
こちらもそうなんですがお店で働いている時にブログを作りまして
まあそういった作品等を掲載するようになりました
そうするとですねあの
だんだんとカメラのジャッシーとかそういったところかですねうちにあの作品を掲載し
ませんかとお声がけをいただくことがちょこちょこと増えてきました
はいであの
こちらもそうなんですけれどもまあ雑誌のほかにもですねこういったこれ小説なんです
けれども小説の単行本の表紙なんかにもですね
写真を使っていただけるようなことがあのちょっと増えてまいりました
であの
2年ほどお店で働いたときですねちょっとた社長が体調が悪くなってしまいましてあの
働いていたお店が畳まれることになってしまったんです
私この時に17歳だったんですけれどもあの
その時あのちょっともう一度人生をどうしようかなと考える機会になりました
まさに27というとまあ友達たちはですね
着実にご自分のキャリアを積み上げていまして大企業に就職した人はだんだん偉くなっ
ていますし
法律家になった友達なんかですであのこう
色々なところで活躍をしているとそう
行った友達たちを見てあぁあの非常に何ですかね
栗東感のようなものを感じてしまってらー皆頑張っているのに私はまだ
なんだか何を気遣っていないような気がすると思ったんですん
その時に本当に自分の胸に心あの自分の心にですね
一問いかけてみてもしかしたら今行っている写真は非常に楽しいし
私が生涯をかけてご頑張るべきものなのかもしれないとそのとき思ったんです
でだいぶ年齢も20も7になっていましたので
ここでねこの機体を逃してしまったら私はもう本当に何も成し遂げられないままに死ん
でいくんじゃないかなと思ったんです
それは本当に嫌だなと感じたなので私はここで写真を仕事にしようと腹を決めました
でですねそこからはやはりもっと修行しなければいけないと私は写真の学校も出てい
ないですし
アシスタントの経験もなかったんですなのでですねあのちょっと望遠がありましてその
グラビアカメラマンの福島よ子さんという方にですねまぁアシスタントとして対応して
いただくことになりまして
そこで何年かあのー勉強させていただくことに
なりました
でもアシスタントのジャイロ時代はですね本当に人生を振り返ってみても多分一番
つらかったです
本当に各重たい小さいをですね毎日ポってもう先生なとついてもあります重たいの20
キロぐらいあったりするんでいけないが
意外と思ってるんですけどあのそういったものを持ってもう朝から晩までもう機材の
使い方から現場の礼儀に至るまで色んなことを勉強させていただきました
ただまぁこのときの経験がですね今非常にバッジの糧になっています
アシスタント時代をですねあの終えてからは予約は写真家として活動するようになり
ました
で今はですねあの人物の撮影を専門に行っている先生についていたので私も人物撮影を
メインにしていますこういったタレントさんの撮影もいたしますしこういった
インタビューの撮影ですとか
対談の撮影というのも奥させていただいてます
みなさんの身近なところだとこれ慶應カードという慶應義塾のクレジットカードがある
んですけれども
どちらの会報誌のあの表紙の撮影なんかもさせていただいていました
また現在はですね慶應義塾の丸の内シティキャンパスというキャンパスがあるんです
けれども
そちらの web なんかの撮影も今させていただいています
あとは8 o 4仕事としてはあの初期のころからお世話になっているまあカメラの
雑誌
あのこう記事を書かせていただいたりというのも非常に多く
やらせていただいています
そしてえっとですねもちろんフィルムカメラも大好きなフィルムカメラも未だに大好き
なのでこれフィルムカメラで撮ったものですけれどもこういった寝入るまで撮った写真
そしてそれはお仕事でよく旅の写真なんかフィルムで撮ったりっていうのを多く
させていただいてます
あと意外に増えたお仕事がまあこのってど x もそうなんですけれども人前でお話し
させていただくということが非常に増えました
私はの本と人前に出るのすごい苦手なんですけどもともとなんだかこう
写真をきっかけにですねちょっとそのあたり自分買われたような気がしてます
はいで今ですね特に休みというものを設けておりませんで毎日何かしら仕事をしてい
ます
撮影がない日でもですねやはり原稿書いたりですとかまぁ何らかの仕事をしています
よく休みなくて平気だねぇって言われるんですけれども本当に毎日何かお姉させて
いただけるという環境が非常にありがたくて何よりも毎日楽しいので
全然休みがなくても平気です
やっぱりあの写真という自分のまあ大好きなものにこれが人生をかけてまぁ頑張るべき
ものなんだというのに出会ってからですね
気づけばご自分の人生と他人の人生を比べることが全くなくなりました人に劣等感を
抱いたりとか
ねぇなんかうらやましいなと思うことが本当になくなりました
振り返るとやっぱり自分の中に芯みたいなものが全く無かったからやはり人の人生と
比べてしまっていたんだなということに気付きがつきました
やはり今はの本当に芯のようなものができたのであの自分の音心に忠実に何か行動でき
ているような気がいたします
ってですねホットあの皆さんにお伝えしたいことがあるんですが私はやりたいことが
分からないままに結構長い間来てしまったんですがそれまでにやってきたことっていう
のも実は意外と無駄になっていないということに
た金あの最近それを実感しています
具体的に何かっていうとたとえばですねまた仕分け
5 aa を書いたりするので撮りたいイメージっていうのが頭の中にあるんですけど
も
まあそれをですねまぁ結構簡単に会に出来る前は写真に落とし込めるんですねそれはの
昔やっぱり漫画とか映画好きだったからっていうのがあるんじゃないかなと思ってい
ます
あとはですね私は写真写真に結構感情が乗ってると面白いと思うんですこれどういう
気持ちで撮ったんだろうっていうのが分かるようなもの
私結構感情が載ってる写真って得意なんですけどそれはい音楽をやっていたことに関係
があるかなと
メロディーに感情を乗せてまあ演奏するのと写真に好感情を乗せていくというのは結構
似てるなと思ってます
はい後はその法律をやっていたときに得たロジカルな思考回路ですとか文章を書く力と
いうのは今仕事で本当に役立っています
お年なんで駆け出しの頃からまあね生地のお仕事とかをいただけたのはそのまあ法学部
時代の結構経験が生きているんじゃないかなと思ってます
あの意外と感情的なんで写真っていうのはそれをですね割と議論的に説明できる人って
あまりいないんですね
で私割とそれが得意なので結構今それが仕事につながっているような気がします
と web デザイナー時代の経験ももちろん生きてて photoshop とか
そういったソフトが使えるっていうのも大きいですし
あの部分の音ありあらゆることに割と詳しいのでこの sns の時代に結構うまく
写真家としては立ち回れてるんじゃないかなと思います
フィルムカメラのお店で働いていたのでやはりデジタルだけではなく増えるものわかる
というのも非常に今仕事において強みになっています
ってあの私は写真に出会ったのが27歳であの覚悟を決めたのが32歳とかなりねやり
たいことに退社遅い方だったんですけれども
あの
でねそれで今までやってきた事って結構中途半端だなーってずっと思いながら雨32
ぐらいまで生きてきちゃったんですけれども
今振り返るとですね実はその中途半端だなと思ってきた今までやってきたことというの
がその自分の今の仕事に結構な具合で役立っているということにあの気がつきました
今までこうなんかパズルのピースを集めていたような感じでしたが今はそれがぴったり
全部はまったような気がしています
入って最後私が皆様にお伝えしたいのはですね
客人生やりたいことにいつ出会うかというのはわかりません
私みたいに変な偶然で出会うこともあると思います
やりたいことが見つからないという方もですね
どうかあのぜひそういったことに諦めず今興味があることというのはたぶんあると思い
ますのでそのことを一生懸命頑張ってみてください
である日やりたいことが見つかったときにその今までやってきたことというのは絶対に
無駄にならないです
はい
遠回りだなぁと思ってもですねそのいつかやりたいことが見つかった時過去の経験と
いうのはさっきのお話のように必ずあなたのことを助けてくれると思います
なので得たいことがわからないぞという方もですね
ぜひあの目の前のことを一個一個こなしていってみてください
はいタクシーからは以上です流れた聞いていただきありがとうございました
[拍手]